hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how to monitor heparin
therapy still a controversy presented by
David Elma Glasson clinical research
scientist retired from fifty-ninth
clinical research division Joint Base
San Antonio Texas I am Christina mahalik
of libraries and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of education for
children's and webinars before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
Freud window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please put
it on the support button at the top
right of the presentation window or the
Q&A button let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner that's
all of the process to obtain your credit
now please join me in welcoming mr.
McLaughlin I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Kristina and by the way I just found out
that Kristina is a fellow veteran and
Kristina thank you for your service she
actually went through the bates where I
was working at almost the entire time of
my career for the military today's topic
how to monitor heparin therapy still a
controversy is
because there are a lot of people who
are still confused about whether to use
the anti factor 10a for the apt t-test
for monitoring heparin I'm going to take
you through quite a few things today
some research that I've done to support
the thing presentations and manuscripts
that are out there that gets pros and
cons on both sides of the issue it's
come up because a lot of the places that
have been doing like anti factor Tenet's
for a long time to monitor heparin oide
have switched back to a PTT because of a
change of staff and personal opinion by
particularly surgeons in this area who
are monitoring their patients in the OU
art so is the KU magenta can i factor 10
a SI less effected by pre analytical
variables and monitoring patients on
unfractionated heparin and low molecular
weight heparins in the apt t well that's
what we're going to be discussing today
the apt T has been around a long time
since the late 50s if the most commonly
used tests to monitor unfractionated
therapy but you can't use it on any of
the other heparin oit's
the low molecular weight heparin variety
the therapeutic range came out to be one
and a half to two and a half something
that was brought up in 1972 and you
don't know whether it's the mean of the
normal range the geometric mean whether
it's part of the range it never has
really fully been explained but it does
correspond to what is considered the
therapeutic range of unfractionated
heparin which is 0.3 to 0.7 units for ml
and that's assayed by the anti 10a test
previous studies have decided the
interference of a lot of things you see
here the oral anticoagulants birth
control and in the form of oral
contraceptives lupus anticoagulant
factor deficiencies acute phase
reactants fibrinogen factor 8 specimen
collection is one of the biggest
problems low antithrombin levels I
picked that up early in my career I did
the first antithrombin as I think in
Texas back in the mid 70s and we found
some people of few docs came down and
says our heparin is not working you guys
are doing something wrong and I said of
course have you checked the antithrombin
level of the patient what's that bring
him up to speed on the anti from and
found out we had a whole family that was
antithrombin we called it three back at
that time deficient
the PTT reagent itself is that ellagic
acid isn't a particulate activator can
play a big role in monitoring heparin
and the instrumentation mechanical
versus a photo op it can be a big issue
now anti 10a interferences are things
like you'll see them a lot in especially
in neonates hyperbilirubinemia
hyperlipidemia which can be cleared with
the ultra surface interrogation and the
anti 10 assay can be used to monitor all
heparin analogs and unfractionated
heparin and to direct oral
anticoagulants which i used the acronym
doe access one thing about the
hyperbilirubinemia I got a question when
I gave a presentation at a ECC this
summer and someone said what happens
when they're using TPA to tissue
plasminogen activator in other words
you're working with clot busting it
comes down as a laboratory totally read
and that's an answer that I have not
been able to find out what to do on that
you could probably try diluting it out
with a normal plasma and then possibly
going by the dilution but I'm still
gathering information on it if anybody
is having that issue I'd like for them
to contact me to see how we can
counteract that
now the therapeutic grains we already
discussed for unfractionated heparin and
for the low molecular weight it's 0.5 to
1 point 1 or 1.2 people vary on that
depending on the institution
unfractionated heparin itself works with
the antithrombin which is natural
anticoagulation of protein whatever it
starts the coagulation mechanism you got
to have something to shut it down and
that's one of them the heparin binds
antithrombin it changes the conformation
of both reagents where they lock
together and it increases the
anticoagulant activity heparin by itself
won't work without the antithrombin
present or it's extremely slow so it
speeds up the in activation of thrombin
at that point and it's slowly active it
slows the coagulation activity primarily
by inactivating
Dromund which is 2a and 10a it actually
does work somewhat throughout the entire
coagulation cascade where you have
activated systems but
primarily the 2a and 10a of the most
explosive and what's major and heparin
approximately equally binds to a intend
a little bit difference and if you're
using a kit I strongly invite you to use
the ones that are 2a activated attend a
activated for when you're dealing with
some of the kits that are out there to a
is a little bit unstable now why do we
monitor well there's a wide variability
of heparin activity at everybody if but
it has nonspecific bindings to plasma
proteins blood and endothelial cells it
can bind particularly to fibrinogen and
factor eight the acute phase reactants
and which when elevated will decrease
the effectiveness of heparin and the apt
T times in other words you've got an
elevated fibrinogen I'll show you some
of this a little bit later on specific
patients it will depress the length of
the a PTT you can make it lot shorter
and there's a big reason particularly
this is the weight based medication that
is used in an equation activity you've
got to know the patient's weight exactly
and due to a difference in body mass
index a story I can tell you very
quickly is when I was doing a research
protocol which I'll be talking about a
little bit later one of the problems I
had I wasn't getting the heparin that I
thought I was supposed to be getting
according the doses that the patient
allegedly was supposed to have and the
pharmacist and I both checked everything
out yeah everything was working we tend
our stuff to other laboratories they
send it back you know to the companies
for analysis and we got we were supposed
to what we found out was that the nurses
on one unit or the personnel on one unit
we're not actually weighing the patients
they were taking their word for how much
they weighed and one patient that told
me she weighed 160 pounds I gave her
kind of the stink eye and I said really
and she goes honey if my husband knew
how much I weighed I'd really be in
trouble now that's not taking a shot at
a gender or large or people who are a
little bit overweight but we've got to
know exactly how much they weigh in
order to give the right dose also found
out that
sometimes particularly with
unfractionated heparin people that are
on an IV but they were being sent to the
clinic they were being disconnected
they'd missed their dose and they
thought oh well we'll make it up later
so you've got to really be able to work
with your pharmacy floor personnel and
laboratory all together to give them
begin to positions the proper result
they need to treat the patients and
different diseases can cause the issues
also its uses are it's primarily there
to prevent the treatment of spontaneous
or ijen a venous or arterial thrombosis
thromboembolism and that's something the
iatrogenic is what's caused by the
procedures that you're doing if you're
having open hearts if you really want to
know what your heparin levels are going
through there and how it's being handled
decrease morbidity and mortality
associated with trumbo emboli disorders
of course your deep vein and pulmonary
embolus mi is unstable angina coronary
angioplasty bypass which I've been on
when I had an aortic valve replaced so I
was very happy that they were getting it
I was being anticoagulated properly ECMO
which is used a lot particularly in
neonates that are born prematurely
stroke and transit systemic attacks
heparin OIG's have used then and then
later they've switched over to different
medications
one thing about unfractionated heparin
is it's not very portable has to be
treated in the hospital usually okay so
how do we monitor it well the aPTT has
been around forever and it's what people
are used to and if you learn it in
medical school I'm not going to change
that some people's attitude not
everybody's but it's a problem in
communicating with people on we've got
new updates the goal one and a half two
times the mean of the control value we
talked about this and being an
equivalent to the point three point
seven units by the anti 10a the intent
is to become therapeutic within 24 hours
if you've got your stuff therapeutic
during that initial period you have a
statistically high problem of having a
BTE reoccurrence and it's also very
clinically important the dosa actually
may be more important than the a PTT
predicting the clinical efficacy if they
give it you know without the measuring
it sometimes that has to happen if they
don't have the availability they should
there is a balance risk between clotting
and bleeding with this drug also the
relationship between super therapeutic
abt and bleeding is less clear
in fact I once had to testify in a
serial-killer nurse case that's coming
back in the news lady by the name of
Janine Joneses was responsible for
possibly injuring or killing it many as
60 patients and I had to testify on the
second one that she was tried on and the
grand jury asked me they said well what
about the dose is too high how can you
tell when they're going to bleed and I
said that information is not out there
we don't know because everyone
individually is different and we just
have to see what's going on we have
specific levels that we look for as
being critical but it's no one they'll
start bleeding that isn't clear and I
haven't seen the publications out there
it'll stand alone that will give you
that information okay monitoring heparin
there are hemorrhagic complications due
to underlying clinical morbidities and
when you're dealing with a large
hospital population you're going to see
everything I've listed several of them
here
the one that troubles me the most is the
age greater than 65 they seem to stamp
that on everything it since I'm older
than 65 now it's something that you're
immediately classified ad but as you can
see a lot of things can also interfere
with it from a treatment standpoint you
gotta weigh the risks factors affecting
the aPTT first off the pre analytic
variables due to patient or sample
collection factors and that's something
I'm going to talk about and the research
protocol that I did that we published a
couple of papers on about how the pre
analytic variables really affected the
testing and it also was would have
affected the physicians treatments when
I showed them the data I said what would
you do with this aPTT result and then
the analytic variables themselves do the
processing and testing in the laboratory
and we're going to talk about some of
those pre-analytical variables sample
volume the 91 blood to antiquated ratio
is pretty critical in monitoring
a bgt not so much the anti 10a which
we'll see a little bit later transfert
and storage time within an hour of the
collection and we'll specify this a
little bit later you should have that
sample spun down and separated if it's
over four hours still on the cells
forget it if it's over four hours of
testing and it has not been frozen or
you know if hasn't been frozen and then
rethought properly you're going to have
a problem there the citrate
concentration 3 8 vs 3 - well in this
country we pretty well established the
fact that 3 2 is the way to go because
it more closely represents the
physiologic situation in the blood but
in many foreign countries are still
using 3/8 so you might run across that
the patient hematocrit if it's greater
than 55 you know you have to make an
adjustment on the amount of citrate
involved and the interfering substances
that we talked a little bit about
earlier Amala says the interest index
anybody remember that test and Lipa mia
and with white PVA you can sometimes do
something about but not always
all right factors other factors
affecting the aPTT
since purgation speed I got burned on a
research protocol that I was doing one
time because two laboratories were
processing samples and I found out that
the g-force on one centrifuge was
different than walnuts or the other and
I was getting a residual platelets on
one and when the samples were thought
out that was releasing platelet material
and that was shortening the times on the
assay that we were using you got to
check it every six months to make sure
you're getting a residual platelet count
of less than 10,000 more platelet free
the better also residual platelets can
release pf4 which is your neutralized
plate the factor for which is your
neutralizing heparin reagent type of
reagents that you use the concentrations
of calcium chloride varies from vendor
to vendor each particular lot number
will give you a different assay with the
aPTT
the time to testing we just discussed
that one hour it processed four hours to
test before freezing ideally - 70 is the
way to go
you have to study early in my career
where everybody was saying well what
should I keep this in that can I keep it
in the refrigerator overnight can I just
put it in the refrigerator freezer I've
got to -20 but I don't have a minus 70
we did some small Studies on that and
found out that minus 70 was the best way
to go anything below minus 50 is good if
we found it sometimes in a week's time
storing at minus 20 we lost as much as
50% activity in certain specimens even
at minus 20 so minus 70 is the best way
to go thawing method 37 degrees from no
more than 5 minutes some of the factors
are thermal labile particularly factor 5
and factor 8 and you can lose activity
there if somebody forgets and let's just
sit in there for about 30 minutes all
right other variables that affect that
may cause the elevated aPTT
taste Authority on heparin direct raman
inhibitors the director or lana
coagulants warfarin or coumadin warfarin
one study shows that the ABT prolonged
about 16 seconds for each 1.0 increase
in the inr that's a few years ago but
when the inr goes up you've got factors
for being decreased that will be picked
up in the a PTT particularly the vitamin
k dependent factors like factor 9 so
you're going to have elevations and
problems there factor deficiencies such
as haemophilia von Willebrand disease
factor 11 will increase it now ones that
don't increase it bleeding risk but art
will still cause the problem with the
appt are you Lukas anticoagulant factor
12 deficiency freak in fact the person
who the factor 12 is named after
actually died from the thromboembolic
brief Alec Alec Rhine and the high
molecular weight kind antigen or the
Fitzgerald factor will also cause an
elevated aPTT but will not increase your
bleeding risk now monitoring the heparin
or using the anti factor 10a
it's used to test the unfractionated
heparin and it's the only assay for
monitoring low molecular weight heparin
such as in aqsa Perrin Delta Perrin
tenza Perrin Northrop Aaron Vonda
paradox or the direct oral
anticoagulants with one exception on the
direct oral anticoagulant it will not
let you monitor Pradaxa or dabigatran
and why is that because it's a to a
effected direct oral anticoagulant and
all the rest of martin a's the
commercial names for enough SAP Aaron
are like lovenox for Delta parents
fragment for tensile Perrin it's you
know help and for Nord apparent or its
s2 it's fracture Perrine or Pradaxa
depending on where you are now you can
use a single calibration curve or a
universal hybrid curve with universal
calibrators with one exception each with
well actually to the font of paradox or
a Rick's truck it doesn't it's a pin a
saccharide that does not quite act like
the other heparin oi to do and so you
have to use a single calibrator for that
and also for each of the direct oral
anticoagulants there is no universal
calibrator presence you have to use a
anti ten a test with a specific
calibrator for that now one of the
problems that we had and we first
started doing anti Tenet's and still do
is somebody seems down a request for a
factor 10 this is a big communication
problem and it actually started me on
one of my research projects because I
could not get we needed to know you know
like okay you really want an anti 10a
you don't want a factor 10 but we need
to know the type of heparin it's on and
when I call the unit I asked the
responding RN I said so you guys really
probably don't want a factor 10 activity
that's a real rare bleeding deficiencies
the person actively bleeding no I said
so do you want something for an equation
like heparin
yes heparin I said okay what kind of
heparin heparin no it's a nun
fractionated is one of the molecular
weights its heparin and hung up on me I
go wow so we
go to the you had to send the pathology
resident of the unit to find out what
type of heparin oi was and I thought you
know the lab shouldn't have to guess we
should just be able to run the assay and
give the information back and they
should know what type of heparin oeid
they're on but the chroma genic fact NSA
is an awesome essay if you're monitoring
somebody who has something like a lupus
anticoagulant and you're putting them on
like coumadin and you need to monitor
and and it's interfering with the PT and
the PTT and you need to monitor what's
on and one of the papers that I wrote a
few years ago and Terry Roseboro has
also wrote some stuff on this and as
well as Steven mall with Tom or tell it
Duke where they used to be where you can
use the coma genetic factor ten essay
and it has no interferences by those
other methods in fact it's more accurate
than the INR it's accurate because the
INR once it gets above four is woefully
inaccurate and you can have people with
factor ten levels with a that are normal
whether it like 40% when they have an
INR 12.5 so if you want some more
information on that I can provide it to
you later but I know that everybody has
experienced this problem of getting a
factor 10 when they really want an anti
10a that's why I kind of threw it in
there now here are the advantages it's
not susceptible to the interference from
any of the acute phase reactants like
fibrinogen to fibrin it's not influenced
by any of the factor fishes these with
the exception of antithrombin if it gets
below 50% activity I have not seen a
method yet where it hasn't been affected
that worried the antithrombin has to be
added to it even some of them were they
add antithrombin is a problem most of
everybody is going to the non
antithrombin gets when they're using the
antithrombin assay so the patient's
plasma furnishes the antithrombin that
is evident that's needed in there now
it's not affected by under-filled
collection tubes or citrate
concentration I'll show you this a
little bit later where we purposely use
the six to one verses 9 to one
anticoagulant ratio
citrate 3.8 versus 3.2
so you know it's no longer necessary to
establish an apt therapeutic range which
is extremely laborious time-consuming on
collecting the samples and the
availability of the samples and you can
check the reference their blood
coagulation and fibrinolysis uh I'm the
author on that advantages using the 10a
it gets you in the heparin therapeutic
range faster that's a big plus less
testing let's check the dose adjusting
less blood draws study using 268
subjects on unfractionated heparin and
randomized into two groups for 10 a or
PTT testing you can see that the people
in the ten eight group in range are 67%
of the time in the heparin therapeutic
range and the PT group there are only
33% of the times very interesting thing
it also is in coumadin one of the
problems with that is it depends on
where you're at but Xarelto or
rivaroxaban was held up because the test
group that they used to monitor against
only had 58 percent of the people in the
therapeutic range of two to three during
the study
and that is abysmal in our coumadin
clinic which you should see about 3000
people I don't know what they're seeing
a month I don't know what they're seeing
now if we got below 80 percent we felt
like we were doing something wrong but
across the country the average was about
55 to 60 percent of being in the
therapeutic range that's how hard that
drug is to control and a subsequent
study by dr. Ross Perot also showed in
using a dosing nomogram which he was the
person given most of the credit for
coming up with the best dosing noma
grams for the heparin oits
showed that the anti 10a range got you
there in 16 hours and 8% of subjects and
87% at 24 hours PTT doesn't even come
close to that as you can see down in the
next study it only got through a 43%
range using the apt only with longer
times to reach therapeutic levels in 24
hours
now most of the anti tenant well several
of the anti 10-day tests that are out
there now I have a liquid assay format
where you don't have to reconstitute
anything you can just pull it out of the
refrigerator slap it on and get it ready
to go a long disability time most of
them are up to about ten days
no reconstitution as I said necessary it
reduces reagent waste you can have it on
the machine longer you don't have to
toss it out daily you don't have to have
somebody mixing it back and forth
pulling 10 MLS out here and adding 5 MLS
back and all that type of stuff or
reconstituting the lyophilized reagents
and with the PTT there are some that are
still alive but a lot of them are liquid
now but it's still an issue if you've
got to take time to put it together and
you still always have the advantage or
disadvantage of human error there so it
is also eases storage issues a more
precise major of the the with the anti
10a then the a PTT gives you and it
reduces that's one thing that just came
out recently at the Belkin 2016 saw that
it reduces blood transfusions in
different disease hemorrhagic states
from the four point seven to seventeen
and a half percent that's a big saving
on money and it's a lot easier on the
patient because we found out that blood
transfusions don't exactly they're not
exactly benign like we think they used
to be in fact I refused to have blood
products unless it was absolutely
necessary life-threatening situation I
went on that with my surgeon and she
said fine and she said you got down
pretty low on your platelets she were at
the forty one thousand she said another
eleven you'd have had a six-pack and I
thought interesting but I did escape
that monetary unfractionated heparin
with anti 10a the rationale for change
cost
I'll give you specific some numbers in
dollars and cents a little bit later but
it gives you a shorter time to
therapeutic range as you can see within
six hours with the anti 10a within six
hours 54 percent were already there
versus twenty seven percent for the a
tt within 24 hours 74% vs. 63 percent
and less dosing changes almost it's
almost twice as much 1.7 versus one for
the aPTT over the anti 10a
now when do we monitor low molecular
weight heparin oits it was brought out
there like so many of these other drugs
like the director oral anticoagulants oh
you don't have to monitor this or you
don't have to measure this oh except if
a few special situations like they talk
about overdose pregnancies extreme body
weights high or low children and renal
insufficiency and we've also found out
in some there's been some talk at some
of the meetings that I've attended in
the last couple of years that all
diabetics that are on the low molecular
weight heparin should be monitored they
found out that they had better outcomes
with that when they're having to use
heparin oit's
if they monitor them so they're a lot
more effective than unfractionated
heparin and preventing and treating deep
vein thrombosis
all right monitoring unfractionated
heparin with the anti 10a the rationale
for change we already talked about that
in airs anywhere from the average of 28
hours a night na versus 48 hours of the
apt t more test results were within the
therapeutic range 66 verses 42 and less
rate changes within 24 hours point 8 for
the 10 a and 1.6 for the apt T now this
is another study by Gravelle who
published in the annals of
pharmacotherapy so you've seen about
four different studies for the anti 10 a
comes out much better every time
and there is efficacy to back this up
now the ideal assay which what you see
before you
linear assay the apt t is not linear in
any way shape or form
the precision okay if you get 10% you're
really doing good you should get around
5% depending on what you're using but it
still it really matters what your
reagent instrument combination is is it
standardized no you don't even have an
ISI value like you have with the INR
even though there's been an attempt ever
since it was invented to standardize
it's just not there is it readily
available yes does the heparin anti 10 a
yes it is readily available but a lot of
laboratories aren't set up to use it and
I have mixed thoughts on that but you
know if you're going to be giving out
heparin you should be able to give them
the best tests available to treat the
patient or have a laboratory you can
send it to very quickly with a good
turnaround time inexpensive we'll talk
about that you know yes the apt T is
everyone thinks 10 a is too expensive
but when you add all the factors in
which we'll discuss it's about the same
it's within cents of one another without
the hassle of having to Reese and ER
dyes it and I'll tell you the
calibration curves on the anti 10a the
one that I use I only had to recalibrate
twice in six months
that is incredible also when I compare
it to other vendors reagents they almost
always come out exactly the same yet the
PT teens when you compare the difference
in reagent instrument combinations it's
all over the place
so the 10a is more standardized all
right now I'm going to talk about a
research protocol I published the two
papers on this one in lab medicine the
other one in blood coagulation and
fibrinolysis where we had a group of
patients that were receiving a low
molecular weight heparin or
unfractionated heparin and they were
consented for the study we went through
the art local institutional review board
through the Helsinki protocol and it was
monitored through the surgeon general's
office of the air force he was also then
monitored by the Surgeon General of the
United States twenty-six subjects were
receiving the low molecular weight and
twenty individuals were receiving
unfractionated heparin actually I went
over that amount and I got called in
front of the IRB wanting to know why I'd
exceeded my value and I said well I sent
you a an amendment you guys just haven't
got it yet
the reason was it's what I discussed
earlier I was finding people that were
supposed to be on heparin and we're
showing no heparin at all or extremely
low levels and we finally found out why
issues of the patient not being there
dipping with those and I found out that
eight o'clock meds didn't necessarily
mean eight o'clock there was an hour and
a half window in there where they were
giving the drugs out and they're looking
at me like okay so we need to tighten up
a few things back to the units it's
really not the fault of the units what
it is is you've got a drug that has to
be handled properly proper awaked proper
nomogram sport has been spelled out and
also the proper times to give it and
testing you've got to test it within a
certain time period after you give it
and so then you've got to know when was
the person actually dosed to give proper
units because then you might give them
too much next time or undergo soon the
time after that in our study we looked
at a full range anything by the way
in the range asset for the
unfractionated heparin anything below
0.05 is essentially noise all the
manufacturers will tell you that
anything below you know that level pay
no attention to because it really isn't
an accurate value the low molecular
weight subjects were anywhere from 0.06
to 1.2 to and you can see the wide range
that you have up there in the ages the
twenty-year-old
actually was a this was a person who was
an Iraqi war veteran who I said kind of
young to be on heparin for a pulmonary
embolus he said yeah he said
unfortunately I was using a heavy a
piece of equipment to dig into a mass
great burial site and it booby-trapped
it with sarin gas and it affected my
lungs and I had a pulmonary embolus
before they got me out of there and I'm
thinking wow I'm glad that we have
heparin and we're able to treat you but
thank you for your service so when you
work with military you see things that
other people don't see and it's a like I
said I was glad that he got back and got
back safely but he was the person on
that study that who was the 20-year old
time pre-existing conditions included
not limited to coronary artery disease
an apostle with an antibody syndrome
deep vein thrombosis recurrent
spontaneous abortion I was in I got the
good luck to be in one of the first
groups started using low molecular
weight heparin and aspirin to get people
through a full term of pregnancy we had
a group of individuals that we had 16 of
them who had never been ever to carry
past the first trimester and we found
out that almost all of them had an ANA
phospholipid antibodies syndrome lupus
anticoagulant and they had never been
able to get through they tried them with
prednisone and aspirin and what have you
well they started using the low
molecular weight heparin and they were
monitored each step of the way on each
visit that they came in they were
submitted they were administering their
own low molecular weight heparin sat
home and they got 14 out of 16 through
full-term that
pretty cool and also pulmonary embolisms
can be an issue also a lot of the
subjects were also taking oral
anticoagulant therapy
each subject we drew six tubes obtained
and what I hope was a single alter at a
traumatic venipuncture because I
collected about 90% of them and then we
split them into three groups
3.8 versus 3.2 sodium citrate and a seat
Tab 2 which I don't know if it's still
available in the state that Sanford
citrate theophylline adenosine is diaper
it them all these are all obtained that
I think we use BD at the time that tube
was supposedly one that has the most
damping effect on the release of
platelet factor 4 and we took a look at
that as well in our study and I'll show
you those results a little bit later
later we each had a stage headed tube
you're on a normal draw of nine to one
blood anak migrant ratio and a short
draw of six to one to see if this would
have an effect on the anti 10a we use
descriptive statistics the t-test or the
analysis of variance and linear
regression in our statistical evaluation
of the study plate the pullout
was obtained by we sentence you to 2500
G & G force or your RC F for 15 minutes
we went a little bit longer than
normally during the lab usually most
people use 10 minutes guaranteeing a
platelet count of less than 10000 and
each sample was checked for that and
stored at minus 70 degrees and took
ready for testing all specimens had an
apt T in a coma gene again i-10 a
performed on each specimen regardless of
the type of heparin being given and each
specimen had an anti ten a result for
the each calibration curve the
unfractionated the low molecular weight
and a hybrid are now most people are
calling at the universal calibration
curve with the anti 10a test the apt
teen reagent was the PCT a region from
diagnostic estado now this test the road
chrome heparin assays in style has been
reformatted and is no longer called that
so star though is selling an under a
different thing this is one where the
antithrombin is not added the analyzer
was an sta our automated coagulation
analyzer I think now called an evolution
plus max all the collection tubes of
course were the standard non wettable
siliconized all obtained from BD now
here are the first results on the
unfractionated subjects using that was a
analyzed using the analysis of variance
which will give you the descriptive
statistics and your F value and
primarily your p-value less than 0.05 is
statistically significantly different as
you can see here starting here and going
straight
down the values are really tight
regardless of 3.8 normal draw three
point eight short draw three point two
normal draw three point two short draw
the seat adds normal draw and short draw
the apt T's very interesting you can see
the worst one here was one hundred and
twenty seven point two strangely enough
the rest of these came in to where the
ranges were sort of closed out they're
very elevated and you know our normal
range is usually about 28 and 35
depending on your reagent and the
p-value was point nine four eight once
so we had good agreement but this can
really fool you I'll tell you why if you
use something called accumulative
summary you might get a mean sometime of
60 seconds where the range is 40 to 90
and then you'll get the same range of 60
seconds where the range is 35 to 70 you
can be fooled by that and so you want to
look at though at how close the anti
10-8 testing values were now in this
group of patients here this one let me
see 62.8 this one and down here
bottom two sixty two nine six so you've
got six to eight four
this patient here and for the sake of
everything will go by the PTT reagents
here and this is the normal draw 3.2
percent I had these two one of the
co-authors on this paper dr. rich
Kruszewski who has gone on to become
very well known and the area of
cardiovascular research and clinical
treatments I said okay what would you do
with this patient he said oh I'd give
him more heparin that PTT is way too low
and on this patient here I said what
about here that's the thirty five point
eight seconds by the way and he said I
would definitely increase that one and I
said what about this one here with you
know look at this here but with this
here where you got ninety one point six
seconds he said I would probably leave
that alone or cut back a little bit and
I said fine rich you would have screwed
up three patients because look at what
their chromogenic anti 1080 levels were
one up here had an elevated fibrinogen
of about 600 this patient had an
elevated factor eight level that was
around one hundred and eighty percent
activity and the bottom one down here
that as 0.05 is a lupus anticoagulant
that's why he had extremely long PT T's
and the anti 10 a test you know was not
working properly so that you can see you
on actual patients the problem
now the anti 10a a PTT results on low
molecular weight subjects you can see
here again we saw similar values the
p-value is 0.9 505 9 this is what I'm
going to show you here is you not
supposed to use the PTT for low
molecular weights but look how it will
affect the test it's slightly prolonged
every single group
now it wasn't statistically
significantly different but the
prolongation was there okay the single
versus hybrid curve now I hope you can
see here here we had the unfractionated
calibration curve here we have the
hybrid curve so you got specifics and
then you've got here the low molecular
weight calibration curve and again
you've got the hybrid curve up here
we've got very good correlation here up
here it's like 0.95 almost 0.96
and here 0.985 for extremely close no
difference between the individual
calibration curves and the hybrid curves
very good correlations there and we went
on to use another company's reagents an
tiara was this one and where we ran 50
samples that were randomly picked over
the range of the study and we saw again
using the single calibrator
on both of them and a hybrid curve there
was no statistical or clinical
difference p-value was point eight eight
really close and very good
this is again using low molecular weight
heparins doing the same thing the last
one was the course the unfractionated
heparin this is the low molecular weight
again very good comparisons and a
p-value is 0.6 and that was because of
the spread of this but it's still not
statistically or clinically
significantly different as you can see
here great correlation and this is where
we use two different lots of ners
reagents and this is actually any others
the distributor - biomed is the company
that puts out that reagent and a great
group of people to work with just like
all the vendors that I've worked with
frankly they're always great to
cooperate and again you see here here's
two different Lots where we use the
unfractionated hybrid curve on the hyper
curve with unfractionated heparin very
close good p-value and you can see the
comparison here great correlation your R
square is 0.95 for your unfractionated
and the low molecular weight your
analysis of variance here not
significant 0.99 you can't get much
better than this on the spread and it's
comparing the height of the rota chrome
hyper now say versus the bio pendant -
method and this is one which shows you
the discordance of the anti 10a versus
the apt a really good study by price
back in 2013 you can see the spread in
here this is your low anti ten a
prolonged PT and your high anti 10 a
with low or normal PTT and this was what
he got on and he found that the disk
ordinance was 43 percent of the time
with the anti 10a range and the PTT
above the therapeutic ranged most of
them were on simultaneous coumadin and
they had an elevated risk or major bleed
and death and you can see the
comparisons down here where you had he
looked at 2321 paired values from 539
subjects so he had a lot of power in
that study and you can see in the box
here
where for example you get the arrow in
here
you
like here you see 15 patients that have
major bleeds in 21 days two consecutive
long PTT verses in range anti ten days
in other words the PT T's were out of
range the in range
anti 10a 163 subjects here again you see
a long PTT versus in range anti 10a the
number was 85 and you can see the
differences between the two and again
out here where PTT was in range and the
anti 10a was concordant very low
percentage values here in comparison
that's a lot of people that's being
measured there okay conclusions the anti
1080 heparin results were not
statistically affected by any of the
collection tubes or the blood
anticoagulant ratio individual a PTT
results in the anti 10 a si showed a
high degree of discordance and this can
lead to inappropriate heparin management
in 3 published studies the reate of
discordance was 43 to 58 percent big
difference when you're comparing PTT s
versus the anti 10a okay the ni 10 a to
reach therapy in another study that the
Richard Marlar just published in
seminars and thrombosis and hemostasis
they used sixteen hundred and ninety
units per hour versus the a PTT which
used 1884 units per hour less heparin
more heparin you see here the group
managed by the anti 10a testing were in
range while the a PTT main subjects
remain septum sub-therapeutic
the anti can a reach therapeutic levels
in 16 hours in 80% of the subjects and
87 percent in 24 hours versus 20 hours
longer with the a PTT and it cost over
four days of unfractionated with the a
PTT
was twenty seven dollars and ten cents
versus thirty one dollars and 46 cents
for the anti tent-mate when labor costs
are factored into phlebotomy lab labor
dosing adjustments to cost for anti 10a
testing is cost neutral so
that old bit about oh yeah it's too
expensive in the long run it's not you
get a better number for the doctor to
treat the patient with the patients
aren't hassles as much the nurses don't
have to make dosing adjustments as much
in the laboratory doesn't have to do
make the collections and the testing as
much with the anti 10a and here you see
a comparison of the apt values to the
unfractionated values this is also in
Marlar study and the shaded areas here
show that in this study with 2187
patients the patients were in range when
you compared to the apt T versus the
concordance with the anti 10a it only
compared 58% of the time so you got
issues how do we handle all these and do
them all at one time now I'm going to be
doing some slides here that I got from a
different source that I have had to work
with
or were they calibrated with different
low molecular weight heparins and as you
can see here when you compare each one
of these individual calibrators with
different drugs that we talked about
earlier low molecular weight heparins
there's absolutely hardly any difference
here in the calibration very nice very
linear essays okay here using the
universal calibrator with a new type of
reagent with that again we are able to
monitor all of the different pepra noids
that you see here the unfractionated low
molecular weight individual curves on
all those the lovenox the fragment you
know half versus unfractionated using a
universal calibrator the curve is a
little bit different but that's just the
instrumentation and the reagent that was
used to own this that slides actually
this one was from IL that furnished this
one I saw it in a study a couple of
years ago I think at a quest meeting in
McLean Virginia
now this is using Universal calibrator
curve here you're the target values up
at the top and you see here look how
close all these values are going from
here down
these are the target ranges that you're
seeing in this range here and each one
of these you can see that they are
recovering almost the same thing all the
way down all the way across so very good
close correlations with the anti 10a
testing on all of the different pepra
noids
using the universal curve so now we
don't have to guess we don't have to
worry about what the floor is sending
down we can run a universal method one
curve one story not five or six like it
used to be and you can get good results
with it the same as you would if you
were running a single calibrator
okay this comes as close to the end of
the presentation what do we do well I
threw this floor
the Greater New Orleans coagulation
conferences they used to have in New
Orleans a great study by coagulation
consultants laboratories down there dr.
Gloria Coker
and I had a large audience of about 400
people several of them were the
physicians several of them were
pharmacists nurses medical laboratory
personnel I said what do we do here
we've got a PT of 26.3 we got an INR of
2.3 we got a PTT of greater than 200
seconds and our anti 10a value is in the
therapeutic range of 0.3 0.7 this is on
patient on unfractionated heparin
almost everybody said nothing don't do a
thing the anti 10a something else is
interfering here the anti 10a test we
would go with it so here's what you have
to do if you want to do the PT T's again
it's just like I said it just came from
dr. Richard Marles paper in 2017 it used
to be we had to use 60 samples 60 that's
the large number to get they all had to
be individually couldn't you use the
same person twice
bla bla bla they all had to be processed
in a certain way did we test fresh do we
Church test frozen it was a problem
here's what he has spelled out collect
appropriate number of samples now this
is all the clsi manual of a with the h21
number determine the apt T on fresh
samples determine heparin level on
pressure frozen samples plot that
against the heparin level on the x-axis
and the PTT on the y-axis determined
bit-line using linear regression
determine the apt value for both point
three and point seven units per ml the
heparin therapeutic range in the PTT
range is between point three and point
seven and all data and calculations must
be available for evaluation but you
still got to use the 10a so why go you
still got use the 10a to establish this
method so if you've already got it
available use it I might be going
against current theory by some people
but I've seen it in practice I've seen
it in research and I've seen it in the
clinical to any clinical situation you
could possibly imagine
and if it was meeting as a patient out
there I would want to be using the 10a
to monitor me thank you for your time if
there are any questions I'll be glad to
answer them now well thank you mr.
Glassman for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask the points do
so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for
today so let's get started with our
first question this question asked so
are you saying that you can use the anti
10a assay for measuring the dough acts
yes the direct oral anticoagulants are
out there now such as rivaroxaban
apixaban a doc Seban B tricks AB and
there are several that have a band to
them and all of them with the exception
of the bigger trend can be used the ni
10 a test with specific individual
calibrators can be used to monitor to
direct oral anticoagulants
and we're getting into situations now
what we're finding out we have to do
this one I had a call from a friend of
mine who's an anesthesiologist and he
says okay what is a PICC Seban so
a rivaroxaban and I said what do you got
he said I got a guy on the table
bleeding and he said he came from your
shop and they said he was on coumadin
and but he'd been taken off so they
didn't tell us he was on this other drug
and I said okay call your pharmacist
number one and number two you know
you're going to have to put on
stabilizers until that wears off because
it doesn't have an antidote
but he said well how much have I got on
board what tests can I use and I said we
don't have one in the United States
anything but are you oh so you're gonna
have to use probably the PT test to
major it he said gee thanks what about
the PTT I said good luck that's where we
were a few years ago now we know that
there are certain situations what if
you're in an accident and you come in in
the ER and they don't know you know
when's the last time you took your
message your non-response or what about
a fear you're you're going to be having
to have some individual surgery coming
up how long do I have to be off of it
how long will I be safe when will I be
therapeutic on a study on the Vega Tran
I had to answer a lot of those questions
for people and the answer is were well
here's what you were the last time you
were in and I had a physician
specifically it's fine to handle these
type of questions so it's a tough one we
don't have the tests that are FDA
cleared and the FDA doesn't seem to be
in a big hurry because Big Pharma said
that they didn't have to have this stuff
monitored just like they said the low
molecular weight heparins didn't have to
be monitored
just like they also said plasma didn't
have applix didn't have to be monitored
we now know that's not necessarily true
in all situations next question Thank
You mr. Bergman glasses let's see the
next question app my lavatory
pathologist say that the anti 10a test
is too expensive as related to the a pee
pee pee test what do I tell them I'd
like to take this presentation back with
you and show them the dollar figures and
take the reference that dr. Marla put in
the seminars in trombonist and
haemostasis 2017 article that's dr. Ari
Mahler
great clutter Richard referenced some
very good the information in there on
the actual cost and if you can work with
your vendor
I'm sure they'll bring it in line for
you and that's the best way to do it
Sean that
you know you can do it equally and the
advantages to it hope that answers
question yeah excellent thank you for
that looks as though we have time for
one more question today
the final question asks which companies
have the universal calibrator in the
liquid and 8na
reagents excellent question because one
of them just came out with one
diagnostic estado has the liquid reagent
and they have the universal calibrators
as well as the individual calibrators
Siemens just brought out a liquid
reagent with a universal calibrator and
IL has had it for some time a liquid
reagent with universal calibrators and
they can be used on all their
instrumentation and I haven't seen the
issues of using another company's
reagents on a different instrument but
frankly most of them are adaptable to be
put on like if you've got a scenery
agent and stock oh is furnishing you
reagents or you've got an il system and
you know for some reason you're using a
different one which most places don't do
anymore but the situation does run up it
shouldn't make that much of a difference
now I will make a incredible difference
on the apt but not on the anti 10a as
you've seen by the studies that we've
shown you today is that the last thing
we have time for
okay guy gives a little closing here
thank you for your time today it was a
pleasure it was a pleasure to talk to
you and I hope I was able to give you
some information that could help you if
you want to reach me by email you can
reach me by Dave McGlashan at
hotmail.com all lowercase one word and
I'll be glad to answer any questions
that you have take care good clotting
from here folks talk to you later I
would like to once again thank you mr.
Rick Glassman for his presentation I'd
also like to
blabbers for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleague who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again here soon at
lab route goodbye